all right so our first story ladies and
gentlemen Elon Musk says he met with
latino civil rights leader but the
organization says she's a rogue
ex-employee
okay uh sure in a separate statement the
leaders of the NAACP the National Urban
League and the National Action Network
blasted musk for unleashing the worst of
human nature
you see Elon look man we were fans
because you said you like The Babylon
bee because you pushed back on the
establishment and then the moment you
get into Twitter not even a week later
you go crawling to these organizations
to try and and he tweets this out to to
figure let them know how we're going to
be handling hate and harassment and what
do they do they attack you for it
Twitter owner Elon Musk I love I love
that that phrase said early Wednesday
that he spoke with the leaders of
various civil rights groups about his
efforts to combat hate and harassment
except one organization said he met with
a rogue employee who was fired last
month and another attendee blasted the
Mogul for unleashing the worst of human
nature
actually said that he unwittingly freed
people to unleash the worst of human
nature with communities of color and
religious minorities bearing the
greatest burden so uh Bravo Elon he
tweeted talk to Civil Society leaders
about how Twitter will continue to
combat hate and harassment and enforce
its election Integrity policies ah yes
what's that all about you see I'm
actually blocked from seeing the tweet
from this diresta woman Joel Roth says
we're staying Vigilant against attempts
to manipulate conversations about the
2022 midterms read on for independent
analysis of our team's work and he
linked to a woman who was an executive I
believe she's an executive or some high
ranking position with new knowledge an
organization that was outed for creating
bots for for manufacturing or doing
something they sent them towards Roy
Moore that so that the media would think
he was being propped up by Russians
that's what this organization was doing
and elon's Consulting them on an
election Integrity okay I'll tell you
what I think the advertisers went to
Elon right away and said we're pulling
out he said wait wait wait like we're
going to keep policing hey trust me
trust me don't leave we need your money
and they said we don't care then he said
okay will charge 20 bucks then the left
said nope we're out we're not paying 20
bucks it goes okay fine eight dollars
eight dollars and you know we said we
were like okay like if if on under the
assumption that Elon was gonna fix the
platform and do right by Free Speech an
actual American values I'll spend more
than eight dollars then Elon has the
nerve to come out and be like actually
we're gonna combat hate with the very
same grievance organizations that will
never be satisfied and why if they are
satisfied they cease to exist none of
these people are going to come out and
be like my job here is done fire me
because there's no more hate anymore
there will always be hate if it's not a
racial slur it's the word groomer so
Elon Musk pandering these people is a
waste of our time I'll tell you this I
am not going to spend any money Elon he
comes out and he's like it's going to be
eight dollars keep complaining all right
bro look
I think there's a net positive here with
you buying the platform I'm not going to
spend a penny I canceled Twitter blue is
bad enough I had in the first place I'm
actually the moment I saw he did this I
was like okay I'm giving them less money
now the moment he did this so I'll tell
you if he releases the information on
the DHS and how Twitter was colluding
with the government I'll I'll pay eight
bucks but he's also got to free the
political prisoners and fire the people
who are involved in the hunter Biden
laptop Scandal yeah this was
disappointing because he kind of tweeted
it like he was bragging about it and you
know you mentioned some of the
organizations but some of them you
didn't mention uh were individuals the
the president of the vice president of
the ADL the NAACP the George Bush
Foundation what Satan wasn't available
you is like truly like are you kidding
me and and then you're bragging about
how you're going to be continuing the
policies when it comes to uh your hate
and election interference and and again
this clearly shows a signal that this is
going in the Raw long Direction and I'm
happy at this time that I have my own
website that I have my own platform
you're probably happy Tim that you have
your own platform as well because at the
end of the day this is very
disappointing news and shows us that
we're going down a very bad Road I'm a
huge advocate of knowing thine enemy and
working with your foe I think Abraham
Lincoln talked about it the best way to
win over an enemy to destroy an enemy is
to make them your friend your ally not
not only do you no longer have an enemy
but you have an extra Ally in case
another enemy appears so I'm into this
idea of like getting to know that you're
the people that are against you but at
the same time Trump putting Bolton in
his cabinet early on bad move Obama
getting the Goldman Sachs team on all
these like bankers and into his cap or
in his inner circle right away they they
start to manipulate you when you
surround yourself with people you become
those people like you are a result of
your closest six friends or something so
at some point you got to just cut you
gotta cut and run and make a move I
think that Elon came into this with no
real plan and now he's trying to build
the plan quickly that's why he wanted to
back out but take a look at this this is
from the Federalist Elon Musk Taps Jesse
smilet hoaxer for Twitter censorship
advice
ah brilliant brilliant look man I like
Elon he does a lot of really cool stuff
but he has an opportunity to talk to
people and he's choosing to talk to the
people who made the problems one of
these guys says what more evidence does
Chicago Police need to call what
happened to Jesse Smith what it is I
hate crime this guy started calling this
stuff out after we already knew it was a
hoax
this and so this is who Elon Musk is
going to why you know what man Elon I
got to tell you he's very naive
I will say it again I met up in Texas
with a bunch of these big Tech Guys
a lot of them were apparently like
worked with or friends with Elon and it
was amazing listening to them speak
because they do not understand culture
they think it's a technology problem the
reason Elon Musk is maybe these people
is it's because he's probably like
everyone has got a good point to be made
technology will solve the problem and
you're like dude
Independents and conservatives already
have stated we've compromised we don't
like The Fringe cult weirdos but they're
allowed to be on the platform and say
what they want to say the French cult
weirdos went to you and said if you
don't ban all of the people we don't
like we're leaving and in response what
Jack Dorsey and vajaga did was okay okay
wait it's this simple the right isn't
leaving even when we ban them and the
left is threatening to leave unless we
ban more right Wingers hey let's ban
more right Wingers let's ban more
Independents and Libertarians and
liberals and now Elon seems to be doing
the exact same thing now it's early
we'll see what happens maybe this is a
cold splash of water in the face that'll
wake Elon up the reason why I'm
frustrated about it and calling it out
right now is because if we don't Elon
will walk down that path and Twitter
will become worse than it was before I
think there's there's a the ideal is a
build a neutral platform where everyone
can co-exist together the reality is
that can't function you need small lots
and lots of small platforms that
interact with each other and so
you need to censor and moderate Twitter
Elon that is your job now you own the
network you control the network you are
the one that needs to censor the network
whether you're censoring it as American
law if it violates American law then
it's off the platform child pouring get
it off the platform that's your light
censorship or if you're going heavy it's
up to you but give the code out to
everyone so that they can make versions
of the site so that they can monitor it
and do it the way they want if they want
to do you know if you say the word the
and you get banned off their platform
fine but we need lots and lots and lots
of terms of service right now we can't
rely on you and your network to do it
and we never should we never should have
to yeah so just to recap so people
understand what's going on here
Twitter's head of safety specifically
cited Renee de Rista she's she's a part
of the new knowledge organization that
Twitter that that Tim just discussed
with their activities with what they
were doing before she's also on video
discussing censorship with Bill Gates
and then under that Elon Musk was like
Hey we're also working with George W
bush in the ADL and we have a diverse
group group of voices here no you don't
you you have a group of individuals who
hate Free Speech you have a group of
individuals who have been trying to
punish people for their political speech
and that's essentially what a lot of
these organizations represented I didn't
know all of them but some of the
organizations that are involved here
that are going to be continuing the
policies as Elon Musk said is worrying
on top of what Elon Musk said after that
saying specifically it's going to take a
couple weeks to make sure that people
are unbanned from this platform a couple
likes what are we waiting for yeah no
seriously I mean as a sign look
you want me to come and spend money
where's the good faith this is the way I
described it earlier today in my morning
show
when I go to McDonald's I can actually
see the burgers under the heat lamps I
know they're they're sitting right there
you tell me you make burgers I can see
the burgers okay I'm gonna give you
eight bucks hand me one of those Burgers
Elon Musk comes in Pay eight bucks and
we're gonna do these things and I'm like
okay well show me that you actually do
that and I'll consider giving you money
for the time being it looks like this is
probably why he didn't want to buy the
platform it's not just about
whether or not he could monetize it it's
that I'm willing to bet he knew I wonder
that no matter what he does the left
will refuse to work with him he's a
billionaire Communists don't want to pay
for things and they're not going to
they're not gonna pay a billionaire so
maybe he was like okay if I buy this
platform there's a lot of Communists in
this company they're going to quit no
matter what I do advertisers are going
to pull out no matter what I do I better
not buy it then he was forced to buy it
now he's desperately pleading with him
please please I'll do whatever you say
they said they were there's already ad
agencies boycotting Twitter so strip it
down to the Bare Bones make it a
protocol or do something let the company
just fizzle who cares man
well probably that Saudi Prince cares I
think he's still got a few billion in
the in the deal right now I wonder if
Elon bid off more than he can cheer with
this one I wonder if the people that
helped him because he didn't front the
44 billion I know there's other people
involved Saudi Prince is one of them um
if they have decision making power I
don't think so I think elon's got Sole
decision-making power but I wonder if
they're like are you going to make this
profitable dude because you said you
were going to make this profitable now
the advertisers are leaving it's go time
where's the what's the income model he's
like 20 bucks a month I mean the way he
went from 20 bucks a month to eight
bucks a month in like a day kind of
indicates that he has no he had no plan
and he's just like almost like having
fun at this point so honestly I don't
think the whole like wait two weeks to
unban people is that big of a deal you
know we waited this long it's been a
year and a half I think that two weeks
is reasonable for a new owner to make a
move on his Network I disagree if if
Elon Musk is not going to come in with a
sledgehammer he's never going to come
with a sledgehammer he's going to keep
trying to say
okay okay leftist okay okay I'm trying
I'm trying please I know you're
screaming at me because you know the
reality is
the I don't like saying the right
because post-liberals dissected liberals
they're not right wing I guess they are
now whatever
there's never any uproar like Twitter
never feared that Dave Rubin or Carl
Carl Benjamin would march with a bunch
of liberalists and classic liberals
Twitter HQ with with pitchforks they've
consistently feared it will be the left
no one cares when a bunch of
conservative rarely I should say but
it's happened but the right typically
doesn't start boycotts and go after big
corporations when they do it works but
the left does it all the time
so right now Twitter be it under Elon
Musk or Virginia they know that they can
do whatever they want and the right has
a higher tolerance for BS and the left
has zero tolerance so if you want to
create a bounce platform you've got to
give the left whatever they want because
the right the adults Will Roll their
eyes and be upset about it the left or
the temper tantrum claim you're trying
to murder them and then quit the
platform in Anger which is what's
happening right now thanks for checking
out this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there